today we're starting a new series called
books and puppies because
uh this
this little one has decided to join me
say say hello to willow
hello this is willow uh so she is the
baby and um she'll be providing vital
vital commentary on um neil neil
gaiman's books um before we start willow
says spoilers and um what did you guys
think of his books tell me down below
before i give you my thoughts i read
american gods by neil gaiman a year ago
and when i finished it i went to talk to
my friend benji over at the tail foundry
and he asked me because he's a big
gaming fan he said what's your favorite
part and i said i really really liked
kind of the end part where shadow goes
back to the small american town and
uncovers a trail of murders of teenagers
and children
and what happened to them it's creepy
it's unsettling it works within the
world of american gods to which benji
looked me dead in the eye and said
that's the worst part i then said that
the worst part was when shadow and
wednesday our protagonists were stuck
hanging around with these old egyptian
gods who are running a funeral parlor it
goes on for ages we spend a lot of time
getting to know mr ibis and mr shaquille
and where they came from and what they
can do and then we just never see them
again
i was reading it thinking oh these guys
must be important characters they must
have an important role to play in the
future
but they just don't they never come back
and that whole section of the book just
doesn't go anywhere
to which benji looked me dead in the eye
and he said that's the best part
ah it's like we're experiencing two
entirely different realities i then told
him that i liked the reveal that
wednesday was orchestrating this war
between the gods to revive himself and
benji said he didn't really care about
that yes hello willow uh that is that is
my hand that is not a sacrifice to you
and here's the thing benji
is right to really understand gaiman's
writing you've got to read the foreword
to american gods i moved to america in
1992. something started in the back of
my head there were unrelated ideas that
i knew were important and yet seemed
unconnected two men meeting on a plane
the car on the ice the significance of
coin tricks and more than anything
america this strange huge place where i
now found myself living that i knew i
didn't understand
but i wanted to understand it more than
that i wanted to describe it
this last line here about him wanting to
describe it to explore it is really the
heart of american gods it is a story
about exploring america about trying to
articulate it's a thesis on what america
is who these people are this culture
that is a weird melting pot of the past
and the present and the future and
its own country and yet also it's so
many other countries thrown into one
when you look at it through that
thematic lens a lot of these little
stories that don't really tie into the
overall narrative begin to make a lot
more sense you know even in an ironic
way because there's all these
subcultures there's no one culture of
america it's distinctly and inherently
and inevitably fragmented right a lot of
chapters look at how certain gods
arrived in america there was a really
vivid one for me about how this west
african god was brought over on a slave
ship by like a single girl and she kept
that alive on her own for a lot of her
life
and it really captured the struggle of
you know holding on to your culture when
so much of it is forcibly taken from you
but it also reflected how america's
culture is so fragmented it's
cosmopolitan it has no central authority
it works only on an individual basis in
this way that section with those
egyptian gods is about how old rituals
don't ever really die in america they
just evolve and change that america is a
place of constant evolution even
wednesday who was meant to be odin is
not the original odin he's not the true
norse odin he's this weird
americanized odin which is such a cool
idea you know america in this way is a
place of preservation it allows all
these things to continue but it twists
them it perverts them it changes them to
fit the landscape even the small town at
the end of the novel that shadow finds
himself in is a real american story it
is a small american rural town
that is dying or should be dying but it
isn't
spoilers
so when you look at american gods as
this vignette of capturing american
culture it makes so much sense but
i don't think i was really there for
that and
that's why it didn't really work for me
i could appreciate it on an academic
level this was intensely creative and
his prose is just makes me want to cry
because i will never write anything as
good as him
but
i i don't think i don't think i was
expecting that and so just didn't meet
my expectations of what the story was
going to be about because i wanted the
story about a war between the old and
new gods which is what he sort of sets
it up as at the beginning and i i didn't
really get that and so i bounced
off it either way gaiman is one of the
best writers of the modern day and i
wanted to give him another chance so
i picked up sandman an iconic gaming
story about
um
well it's hard to say it sometimes to be
honest it is
vaguely about dream putting his realm
back together after being held captive
for years by a cult but like american
gods it meant his
and i mean that see gaiman has a
tendency to make big narrative promises
at the start this is about a war between
the old and new gods or this is about
one of the ancient entities dream
breaking out and wreaking vengeance or
bringing his world back together but he
takes so long to get to the next plot
point that furthers that promise that i
tended to get a bit lost i was reading
this part of sandman told from the
perspective of a cat and it went on for
a long time so i was reading it thinking
this must be important i need to
remember all of this information when it
finally becomes clear about how it
weaves into the narrative i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna see it and it's gonna be great
but um
it just doesn't really it just didn't
really tie back into the core narrative
that much or when it did it was in a
small nominal way and this happens over
and over there is this huge discrepancy
between the time that gaiman spins with
characters or stories and the actual
relevance it is to the overall plot to
the ending which
i guess i sort of struggled with as he
kept introducing more characters and
more subplots i got to the point where i
was asking myself going into them i was
going
am i actually going to need to remember
all of these am i meant to care about
this or is this going to be another one
of those little stories but again like
american gods makes a lot of sense if
you look at it through the lens of an
exploration of american culture sandman
makes a lot of sense if you look at it
as a love letter to the power of stories
and writing and dreams and imagination
because dreams ventures across the
series all these little stories show how
they affect and motivate and break
people it's why the story ends with
shakespeare's team best and why
shakespeare himself plays such a large
role and a really cool one at that i
will admit i want to be clear i love
gaiman's imagination he has just
incredible ideas and creativity that
bleed off the page with the characters
he creates and the positions that he
puts them in everything is very much
vivid you know
but
at the same time
i think i needed a bit more connective
tissue between these stories it's almost
like to me
american gods and sandman would have
worked better as a collection of short
stories each where they're sort of
connected by a general theme you know
looking at these gods and american
culture or
looking at the power of these stories
but
not making those big narrative promises
that sort of lure me into a weird false
sense of oh i'm gonna get this story and
then i get this it's pretty clear and
it's totally fine that he doesn't really
want to write about these big plot
promises they're just a way to vaguely
connect these stories together so why
not do away with them in that case why
not you know and the weird thing is i'm
not really a plot driven reader you know
one of my favorite books is annihilation
it is deeply thematic and a similar way
that american gods and sandman are
deeply characterized deeply internal and
there's there's at no point any real
suggestion that you're going to get all
of the answers uh you think you might
want it's so much about exploring the
atmosphere and feeling and the ideas
behind the novel and i i adored it i was
there for the characters experience but
i was i was never made that plot promise
this is of course
totally up front all to do with my
expectations right this is not a
reflection of his actual writing
abilities or anything like that people
bounce off novels all the time uh for a
bunch of different reasons and
i think this might just be one of those
examples for me so i read american gods
and i had read sandman and i was going
uh is he just not for me
but he's one of the best modern authors
of our day and i didn't want to give up
and that's why i am stoked that i tried
the ocean at the end of the lane the
ocean at the end of the lane is all of
neil gaiman's beautiful writing
mesmerizing themes and characters and
soft world building without any of the
drawbacks it's got a great hook a child
brings back an eldritch or ancient
creature from the mystical otherworld
and it is now trying to ruin his life
family and otherwise
and it's got an incredibly disturbing
scene in it i remember as i was reading
it he's trying to drag a
worm out of his foot like a literal worm
like it's in a hole in his foot he's
trying to pull it out it's really
uncomfortable to read and i was just
like oh oh my gosh and that was
it was done really well though it makes
great narrative promises and follows
through on all of them to a really
powerful tightly written end it's pretty
clear to me that gaiman is a character
writer and he likes writing stories with
relatively few characters like american
gods and sandman both have huge casts
but any given scene or any given little
little story segment typically doesn't
have more than
three you know
and
that exact limited infrastructure is
present in the ocean in the lane there's
really only kind of three main
characters i am not here to tell you to
not read american gods or sandman in
fact i recommend that you read them
because they are incredible and they i
really hope that they they work for you
you know uh i will tell you also to read
the ocean at the end of the lane
but i i i want to talk kind of just
about you know why we sometimes bounce
off books even when the books are
incredible you know even when the books
are
from some of the best authors of our day
they don't necessarily always work for
us even though it feels like they might
tick all of our boxes
sometimes that happens sometimes it does
but i'm really glad to have had the
experience reading them anyway what did
you think of the books though do tell me
down below stay nerdy and i'll see you
in the future